[Musique]
je ne doit plus être le seul à connaître
la formule de la potion magique quoi
brad m'a dit tu dois pouvoir
catastrophe holding qui sait ce qui se
passerait si la puissance de la potion
magique tomber dans n'importe quelles
mains
je veux faire ce sale là dedans par un
droïde pas pourquoi ce serait plus dur
que de trois minutes
[Musique]
oui
une fois je me suis même tordu la
cheville a pas une fois à partir de
maintenant je ne doit plus être le seul
à connaître la formule de la potion
magique où je mets donc partir à la
recherche d'un jeune successeur à qui il
a confié coin tu sais ce qui se
passerait si la puissance de la potion
magique tomber dans n'importe quelles
mains d'hommes avez-vous en tête la
liste des jeunes truites gaulois bien
côté je raconte des petites fiches des
critiques la petite fille cette maison
habitable de pl et érable j'ai été super
dur cela ils sont pas enfuis su le faire
une soupe à l'oignon
ici les mauvais mais qui arrive quand
même à bricoler deux trois trucs on me
surnomme maneaty
et là les très bons dit vas-y mollo sur
la frime quand même
ave caesar de cette caution je te le
donnerai à potion des dragons quelle est
cette manigance sulfurique ce ce soir
c'est la fin du village de crétins
moustachu la fin d'acte ericsson je
verse salade dans du porc un druide
propos pourquoi ce serait plus dur que
d'être pas soigné
détroit
jekel par multi faut taper pourquoi
tomber ça tu sais mieux que ça fait
chaque fois j'ai modifié à 10 sa part
exposé c'est que c'est bon ça explosera
plus
si tu es aussi m'ont dit que poissonnier
va y avoir la performance alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils répondront sans cac et
là tu veux faire le show du coup bah oui
c'est fini
non non moi je pense que je devais être
sur la fin fin